salut quand on parle de mentalisme on
parle souvent de persuasion ou d'
influence aujourd'hui je vous donne
trois techniques pour avoir toujours
raison
alors d'un point de vue déontologique
c'est à vous d'être en raccord avec
vous-même et de voir comment utiliser ça
ou pas mais déjà le fait de le connaître
ça vous permettra aussi de vous en
prémunir
alors bon généraliste en techniques
qu'utilisent les gens qui veulent
toujours avoir raison parmi la multitude
de techniques qui existent en premier
c'est d'insérer une petite torpille
entre les croyances et les valeurs d'une
personne c'est tant pis ça peut être une
croyance vacillante qui va remettre en
cause le mode de pensée de la personne
le but c'est de créer un conflit interne
c'est facile d'avoir des valeurs tant
qu'on a rien qui vient s'y opposer en
termes de croyance un exemple très
connue c'est le test des 1 millions
d'euros vous donne deux exemples un peu
plus concret un qui concerne le youtube
vous allez vite comprendre et un autre
imaginez dans un quotidien que vous
connaissez plus bon imaginons que j'ai
une valeur qu'une valeur que j'ai qui ne
pas faire de placement de produit pour
un produit auquel je ne crois pas qu'ils
ne me plaît pas c'est ce qui s'est passé
d'ailleurs tout en 2016 je n'ai pas fait
un seul placement de produit j'ai eu des
propositions je suis pas contre mais il
n'y avait rien qui après utilisation me
donnait envie de défendre ou de partager
auprès de vous sur la chaîne mais
imaginons pour reprendre le test d'un
million d'euros qu'on propose un million
d'euros pour faire ce placement produit
qu'est ce que je fais à ce moment là je
vais être peut-être tenté de revoir ma
valeur en trouvant des excuses pour
pouvoir le mettre en place
alors là c'est facile puisque ça
concerne l'argent on se dit ok tu est
facile exemples plus concrets vous avez
un pote il vous emprunte toujours vos
affaires vous avez du mal à vous dire
non mais le problème c'est qu'il met
trois plombes à voulait rendre vous
voulez réclamiez mille fois et en plus
si les abîmes vous en parlé plusieurs
fois avec lui il a du mal à l'entendre
même quand vous aurez augmenter ça ne
marche pas trop bien parce que lui dans
sa valeur vous êtes potes et vous pouvez
bien faire ça pour lui c'est sa valeur
c'est pas très grave et puis je suis
comme ça et puis moi je suis un mec
rebelles excellèrent imaginez vous savez
que ce poste est très intéressé par
l'une de vos amis en commun qui
s'appelle virginie dans une conversation
vous parlé avec lui voulait dit que tu
pourras me rendre tel livre que j'étais
prêté parce qu'il ya des génies qui me
l'a demandé c'est assez marrant
d'ailleurs moniz est souvent la même
chose me demandait souvent de vous
prêter les mêmes choses par contre le
genre à me demander pourquoi le livre
était si abîmée c'était pas cool ne pas
prendre soin de mes affaires et
du coup je lui ai dit que c'était toi
qui n'était déjà trois plombes à me
rendre les affaires mais en plus
quelqu'un avait tendance comme ça les
dépiauter un petit peu et là vous êtes
en train de toucher aux désirs puisqu'il
n'a pas envie d'avoir une mauvaise image
vis-à-vis de cette personne là il va
revoir sa propre valeur pour changer ça
et qu'elle change d'avis il est obligé
de changer son attitude vis-à-vis de
vous et donc de changer sa valeur de
base est-ce que c'est clair excellent
technique numéro deux c'est un système
que connaissent bien les gens qui
prônent l'argumentation y en a des
exemples sur internet
ils sont à fond sur l'argumentation
j'appelle ça la conclusion logique non
pertinentes
vous construisez votre argument dans le
but d'avoir une réponse précise puisque
vous avez une conclusion qui est lié à
cette réponse précise et qui selon vous
est imparable
cette réponse précise elle vous
permettrait d'aboutir à une conclusion
logique qui vous ferait remporté le
débat mais souvent vous n'arrivez pas à
obtenir cette réponse précise et bien
pour appliquer cette technique vous
devez juste présentée avant une cause
qui n'en est pas une du tout pour
présenter quand même votre conclusion si
la personne n'est pas attentive ou si
elle n'est pas très courageuse va pas
tout remettre en question
c'est assez dangereux c'est souvent
utilisés et je vous dis pas de
l'utiliser je vous dis surtout dit
vigilant exemple concret jean-jacques
pour la soirée faudrait que tu viens de
me chercher en voiture chez moi
maintenant
non je peux pas venir ça va me faire un
détour un média à prendre quelle route
toi à cette question tu affrontes quelle
route vous voulez l'entendre dire qu'il
va prendre le périph et vous allez amené
le fait que ça va bouchonner et que
c'est pas bien pour lui sauf que l'agent
jack il vous répond simplement et en
plus de venir te chercher ça me ferait
partir beaucoup plus tôt oui c'est vrai
mais par contre en passant par le
périphérique comme tu dis moi j'arrivais
plutôt que toi en passant par les
transports tellement ça va bouchonner et
encore s'il n'y a pas d'accident sur les
routes
alors si au final tu prends la route
secondaire en passant par chez moi tu
évites le périph donc très vite les
bouchons et tu gagne du temps de
l'essence et de la fatigue oh la jolie
conclusion qui vient d'une cause que
personne n'avait soulevé au départ il ne
pose complètement fallacieuse plus si ça
se trouve la personne a utilisé une
technique de manipulation dont je vous
avais parlé celle du pied dans la porte
qui fait que comme il est venu vous
chercher buy va vous ramenez pas ce
qu'il a dit oui une fois ce serait
illogique qu'ils disent non la deuxième
fois alors vigilance parce que c'est une
technique est souvent employé par ceux
qui veulent toujours avoir raison ainsi
que la troisième technique que je vous
présente maintenant dans les topics qui
est d'aristote dans comme quoi c'est pas
un récent dans le viiième topic
d'aristote
il est conseillé à l'arc
mantha teur de ne pas laisser deviner sa
conclusion de pas la laisser
transparaître
et pour ça il ya une technique de ouf
c'est de créer un syllogisme en
mélangeant les prémices alors un
syllogisme c'est quoi c'est une
conclusion qui vient de plusieurs
prémices je vous donne un exemple très
simple à comprendre si à égal b et que
on accepte ce prémices là et si b égale
c est qu on accepte ce prémices là alors
une conclusion du syllogisme serait de
dire à égal c'est on peut pas remettre
ça en question puisqu'on a admis que à
égal b et que b égal c'est comme on n'a
pas envie que la personne elle voit
directement que à égal c'est on va créer
un à égal b-1b égal c'est en les
mélangeant un petit peu dans la
conversation c'est extrêmement utile si
vous savez qu'à la base la personne ne
serait pas d'accord reprenant l'exemple
de la personne qui doit venir vous
chercher en voiture qui prend souvent le
périph toit en fin de journée et ouais
tu perds combien de temps en moyenne
dans les bouchons 1h 2h et ça dépend des
fois
en fait il ya toujours du retard quand
on prend le périph quoi premières
prémices
elle va être bien là soit ce soir par
contre je sais que michel attend que
tout le monde soit bien présent pour
lancer le truc vous une soirée qui est
importante pour lui ça va être important
qu'on arrive tous à l'heure qu'on lui
fasse pas un faux plans plus je pense
qu'il le prendrait mal deuxième prémices
le syllogisme et donc si tu passes par
le périph tu seras au retard à la soirée
et la personne va mal le prendre
et c'est là que vous avez la solution
passe me chercher parce que ça a l'air
d'un petit détour en fait on arrivera à
l'heure à la soirée puisque en passant
par chez moi il n'y aura pas de bouchon
alors si on élargissait et qu'on creuse
et un peu on verrait que peut-être que
jean jacques qui doit partir une heure
plus tôt pour venir vous chercher
il va encore perdu une demi heure après
par rapport à la route alors que s'ils
étaient partis seulement une heure plus
tôt de chez lui serait arrivé
complètement alors il existe plein de
méthodes comme ça d'argumentation pour
avoir raison peut-être l'année prochaine
je vous ferai une vidéo vraiment
consacré dédié à ça avec d'autres
exemples concrets
vraiment je vous dis pas forcément de
les utiliser c'est votre déontologie là
qui rentrent en ligne de compte par
contre si vous avez aimé la vidéo comme
d'habitude vous pouvez lalique et et
vous abonner rendez vous demain à 17h
ciao
[Musique]